Randy Bachman is a legend in the world
of rock and roll he's earned over 120
gold and platinum albums and singles and
sold over 40 million records over his
long career as both a performer and
producer cbc music has declared November
as guitar month in honor of the occasion
they have announced Randy Bachmann's
upcoming vinyl tapped or coming to a
city near you starting in February Randy
Bachman joins us in studio to share some
of the stories behind his songs thank
you very much real pleasure to meet you
thanks pleasure to be here one of the
the things I was interested to learn was
that you actually started out playing
the violin what what made you transition
to guitar EP Elvis Presley after about
seven years of classical violin started
when I was five got very bored and then
saw this thing on television black and
white 2 they blocked off the bottom half
the to you because he was shaking his
legs yes and my mother was there and her
sisters who are younger than her
screaming like my father going this is
crap get this off to Venus that I want
to do that because compared to classical
music which was very dull rock
insurgents up this was exciting you did
anything you want there was no rules you
just played from inside you and I got a
guitars very fortunate to meet a guy
named Lenny Breau who spent a couple I
was 15 then he was 16 it's been a couple
years with him learnt my vocabulary so
to speak and then from then on I've had
a great life let's turn our gaze to the
business of music because you were sort
of in some ways in the classic era you
could record an album sell a ton of it
make a lot of money off the recording
itself everybody was happy and then the
internet hit and changed everything what
advice do you give to young musicians
today that want to make a living making
music because it is damn hard it's very
very hard and we just Canadian Congress
just passed on a bill that was supposed
to give us more row fees I think they
didn't and that was a very hard thing if
it's your passion and you like doing it
like when I started out you play for
nothing it's like a you start a business
you work 20 hours a day to get this
thing up and going because you love it
you're passionate about it you've got to
like that because when things go bad
you've got to like what you're doing so
I've had maybe a dozen or 15 hit songs
people celebrate those living off they
don't celebrate the 300 strikeouts I
mean when Mickey Mantle was the king and
Aaron Hank Aaron people celebrated their
home runs they don't realize they were
also the strikeout King say struck out
eight thousand times but they hit 400
home runs you get a check every quarter
from the music you wrote i do that's a
great thing if i make a door and sell
you a door or I'm a glandular too and I
paint a painting like you know I mean
like whatever you sell that once and you
maybe get three dollars thirty dollars
years later it's like 43 million dollars
is avantco or something like that you
are me when you do as a song every time
it's playing the radio get one or two
pennies and if you have dozens of songs
that are getting played in every radio
station those couple of pennies our play
end up being thousands a day and with
the classic rock form at bat now back
now that's a that's a wonderful earning
it's an annuity so to speak but that's
taken me 40 years and I didn't I didn't
do it for that reason I didn't know that
was going to happen we do your first
record deal you get nothing everybody
takes pieces of you and there's nothing
like there's no piece left for you so
the royalties obviously are important
you've had longevity for other reasons
though as well I know a reviewer of your
recent book characterized it as rock and
roll minus the sex and drugs is that if
we're drugs to you and it's a family
show so we want yeah I know what do you
attribute to your longevity seriously um
well I knew at the age of five when the
teacher went to run said what's your
name of what you want to do as for when
you grow up there's I want to be a
fireman when dr. I said my name is Randy
back when I'm a musician and she said
but what do you want to be when you grow
up and answer the question again I'm
Randy back when I'm a musician I already
wasn't playing costco violent and she
kept asking me to go I ran home so the
first day of school in medicine what are
you doing home so I hate school I quit I
can't I don't know the right answers so
she took me back to school and explain
to the teacher that I already been
singing and playing and it was a
violinist and so I knew that an early
age so knowing that I honor that every
single day I don't never take it for
granted i've never done drugs I don't
drink I've never smoked I've never
smoked I've never drank coffee I just
rock and roll when that's your whole
thing when shooting hoops is your whole
thing you
come the next you know what I mean the
next right the only 30 seconds left but
quick question Paul McCartney was
recently interviewed and was asked we
really admired a songwriters guess who
was his answer that's remarkable that
just shows you the legacy you built
there what do you say to that if you
guys want a jab that must make you feel
pretty good yeah yeah we got to take a
break because when we come back we're
gonna we're gonna take a break first
Randy Bachman unplugged the legendary
guitarist is gonna join Kevin on the leg
and O'Leary stage for a little blues gem
years in the music industry Randy
Bachman has played with just about every
guitar grade of the wrong here out but
there is one accident he hasn't shared
liner notes with kevin o'leary so stay
with us we're going to be back with more
but first you're a Randy Bachman didn't
kevin o'leary
hey
me
you